here we are again
good evening it's a beautiful gorgeous
summer night in new york and here
this place is full of people who want to
talk about holograms and
that's wow yeah world science festival's
so great
my name is john hockenberry first of all
i'm the college dropout
news guy who's going to hang out with
nobel physicists tonight
perfect for this job oh my god um
how did i get here um but uh seriously
you know we think of uh you know this
season as a world science festival it's
the beginning of june the weather starts
to get great you know tonight at uh
uh uh brooklyn bridge park it's supposed
to be one of the best viewing nights
uh in new york and there aren't many
really fabulous viewing nights in new
york so i urge you to do that i mean
it's a beautiful clear night everybody's
out in there some
it's kind of like prom season we think
of the world science festival as
the prom for all the scientists who
maybe didn't get any dates didn't know
there was a prom
and i actually pulled our panel tonight
three clearly did not go to the prom
uh didn't want to talk about it and one
didn't remember
uh at all you may be able to figure out
who who is who tonight
um i'm actually perfect for this uh
gig for another reason because i
actually
inadvertently helped to solve one of the
most serious problems in physics
back in the 1970s i was on a team
that helped to do that i was enrolled at
the university of chicago as an
undergraduate and i
tested into the top of science section
uh basically junior of science in in my
freshman year
and it was taught by a protege of david
schramm
one of the nobel laureates at the
university of chicago late david shran
brilliant physicist
and uh part of the university of chicago
program which gave us enrico fermi and
so many others and
uh chandrashakar and uh and i was in
this program and very excited i go to
the first lecture and uh it was taught
by uh one of these proteges
the central european fellow i can't
remember his name now
and it will become clear why he said
hello everyone it's great to see all of
you here we have very serious problem in
physics
uh the problem is a simple problem
but the serious problem it is too many
physicists
and so in this course if you're getting
b
b minus you'll get f uh
if you're doing a b plus a you will get
a
um i went into the news business and
thereby helped to uh
solve the very serious problem in
physics
of too many physicists so
and a lot of the panelists tonight are
possibly grateful for that
so uh you are here to talk about
uh and to listen to one of the most
exciting
fascinating also difficult uh principles
that's uh
now being kicked around in uh physics
and cosmology
uh the holographic effect and it
involves a couple of concepts that
actually we have a lot of intuitive
sort of sense of uh and i want to
present two of those tonight before we
introduce the panel and get started here
um one is the idea of of information
uh information we we think we know what
information is
right information is very very
like you know you go information
right now now that isn't the new york
subway system
right but it is enough information to
specify
how to get from point a to point b and
if you understand how to read
the subway map you can get from point a
to point b the information isn't exactly
the same as the subway but
if you don't have the information the
subway is useless to you and
and somehow it just it sort of maps
directly and it is a map right it maps
directly onto the subway
and of course now the subway map nobody
has one of these right
it's all on your like smartphone which
means it's stored on a tiny
piece of silicon and so therefore
what the the volume of this can actually
be mapped directly to a volume
you know a one millionth the size take
for example this
anybody got one of these anymore no i
mean
this specifies the number of synonyms i
don't know what the hell it actually is
but uh
it's a thesaurus and it actually also
fits in a
tiny piece of code in microsoft word
we got here the uh just the 8ms okay
oxford shorter uh english dictionary
information i'm going to set it over
here just to remind you of what
information is all about now
information the dictionary isn't the
english language right
the the the the space the universe of
the english language is all you people
talking will you talk now
just talk just turn to your neighbor and
say hello how you doing
right there see that is the that is the
space called that is the universe of the
english language that you are hearing
it is not it is not the same as this
book
but it sort of maps on to this book and
there's enough information in this book
to make predictions
about what it is that you're saying so
that if you actually talk to me
i know what the hell it is that you're
saying um unfortunately
i probably won't know what the hell it
is most of the panelists are saying
tonight so
i may need your help with that
nevertheless
there is information in what they say
the information maps onto a space where
we can make predictions
it is information that allows us to be
conscious beings it is information
that allows us to be living beings if
you think of dna
as information now the information we're
going to talk about tonight is much more
complicated
but the idea of information as a map
as a specification of a much bigger
space is sort of the beginnings of what
we're talking about here
the other thing is holograms right you
know
clap if you know what a hog round
i just said clap if you think you know
what a hologram
is yeah let me introduce our panel
please welcome
raphael busso
let me tell you a few things about
rafael rafael busso is a theoretical
physicist at the university of
california berkeley
he's recognized for discovering the
general relation between
curved geometry of space-time and its
information content
a key idea of the holographic principle
please welcome our next panelist hermann
belinda
rahman belinda is a physics professor at
princeton university in 1988 berlinda
received his phd under the supervision
of
gerard eth rolinda is renowned for his
contributions to string theory
and its application in particle physics
cosmology and black hole physics some of
his current work
explores gravity in the context of the
holographic
principle our next panel is is indeed
nobel prize winner
gerard
parrot hopes to receive the 1999 nobel
prize in physics for his doctorate work
in theoretical physics he's a professor
of physics
and of his many achievements he was the
first to propose the idea
that would later become known as the
holographic principle
and finally our fourth panelist leonard
suskind
professor suskind is professor of
theoretical physics at stanford
university
and the first to give a more precise
interpretation of the holographic
principle using string theory
he's well known for his book on the
topic of the holographic principle
the black hole war my battle with
stephen hawking to make the world
safer for quantum mechanics
it's a fantastic book i highly recommend
it please welcome the panel
back in the early 1970s stephen hawking
wrote down an astonishing equation it
would include relativity it would
include quantum mechanics and it would
include information
hawking's rather simple equation brought
us a step
closer to understanding the relationship
of quantum physics and black holes
when an object crosses over the edge of
a black hole its event horizon
the object enters a realm basically of
empty space of darkness
and it continues to be dragged toward
the center of the black hole toward what
we call the singularity where it gets
crushed out of existence every object
in some sense contains information
because it contains a very specific
arrangement of particles
so where is the information that
describes
the arrangement of those particles where
does it go
hawking's description of this process
was that
the energy remains but the information
disappears
for many years for decades people
wondered
is hawking right is the information
obliterated and disappears from the
universe or
is it still there and perhaps can be in
some way retrieved
the destruction of information was
counter-intuitive and it didn't match
the rest of the things we knew
in all parts of physics we had a
situation where information doesn't get
destroyed so it was a bit puzzling this
debate
furiously went back and forth up through
the 80s and into the 90s
when people finally began to articulate
this
new principle this holographic principle
and what it said is that all the things
that were falling inside a black hole
were somehow captured in a preserved
image at the horizon itself so if the
information is not lost
on the surface information is not lost
inside because they are equivalent
all the information about those objects
what they were like in their
three-dimensional
existence was preserved or encoded on
the surface
of the black hole and that's a little
bit like a hologram
well that suggests that maybe that idea
may apply more broadly to the universe
as a whole maybe
the three-dimensional objects us
everything in the world around us
maybe all of the information in these
objects
is carried is smeared around a distant
two-dimensional surface that surrounds
us
and we're just in some sense a
holographic projection
of that distant data
the holographic principle tells us
something quite astonishing
it says that our ideas of volume of the
the real world in a sense might be a
kind of
illusion
so are we real or are we just holograms
let's begin with that but uh in fact uh
let's first of all remind folks
you guys were direct participants in
that argument that was described in that
film which i think fairly characterizes
the difficulty scientists have not only
in
in sort of grasping and fully
understanding this holographic effect
principle but also explaining it
leonard susskind what was it like to get
into
essentially a pretty big cosmological
argument with stephen hawking and be
careful because hawking's one of my
wheelchair boys
yeah and uh we're really tight we're
really tight
it wasn't that physical what was it like
it was
fun and it was frustrating it was
incredibly frustrating
stephen had a view which was
very very difficult to argue with his
ideas were based on very very sensible
ideas
a black hole is a place where nothing
can get out of but things can fall into
it
and if things can fall into it and they
can't get out they're gone
but then the black hole evaporates
stephen had proven that beyond
anybody's uh doubt and so things fall
into the black hole
they can't get out the black hole
evaporates poof it's gone just exactly
as
brian said it was unassailable there was
no
way to argue the case and yet
some of us particularly myself
very very strongly felt that this really
undermined
everything that we knew about physics
everything that we know about physics
today and even much earlier
was based on a principle of physics
which is so basic
that we sometimes forget to mention it
to our students
it's the idea that information never
disappears
and i'll tell you what that means
information means distinctions
distinctions between things um a
hydrogen atom is not
uh it's not the oxygen atom an oxygen
atom is not a hydrogen atom there are
distinctions between these things
and it was a very very basic principle
of physics
that distinctions never disappear
that they may get scrambled that they
may get all mixed up
but if you start with one configuration
and you let it go
or you start with a different
configuration which has different
information
and you let it go they'll stay different
and stephen was saying exactly the
opposite
no matter what you throw into the black
hole in the end you get out
exactly the same thing it was extremely
difficult to see what was wrong with
what he was saying
it was even harder to make him
understand
that there had to be something wrong
with what he was saying so it was very
very frustrating
but at the same time um it was very
exhilarating to
to come up against this basic problem
of conflict of principles and if
anything can break the impasses in
physics if there are no experiments
available
it's conflicts of principle when
conflicts of principle arise
that's when major new paradigms concerns
that's the excitement that's really the
excitement
howard explain to me why this
problem with hawking this um uh
you know the information can't go away
as it seems
as though hawking's mathematics suggests
it does is different from something like
say
conservation of mass energy where matter
can either be created nor destroyed it's
it's different than that right yes it
was a very
fundamental problem and the way i always
saw it
is hawking was using quantum mechanics
in particular quantized fields to derive
his
results so quantum mechanics went in
as as starting point number one
and then general relativity everything
else and the use of that to derive the
black holes
radiate particles from that it was
derived that was information
and there was information disappearing
well the fact that information
disappears
is at odds with quantum theory itself
so he uses quantum theory to derive a
result
which basically was at odds with quantum
theory
so there had to be a mistake somewhere i
shouldn't call it a mistake because
what he did was by itself mathematically
correct and nobody doubts that
but the final result had something in it
that couldn't be true
and so this is what in physics you call
a paradox
and like my friend lenny has been saying
as soon as you encounter a situation of
this sort in the physical world we are
very happy actually
it is a paradox it means there's work
for us to do we have to clear this thing
up
and if you look at the past you know
quite well that when people start to
clear up paradoxes
new discoveries are being made so you
guys are friends several cases and
that's
why we're all so excited about this
thing is something wrong
the deviation itself seems to be
flawless but there's something wrong
anyhow with the result
you guys are friends then of course we
are yeah
herman let me let me ask you a question
just about this issue of information
briefly and i want you to go back i
definitely want you to go back why why
does the universe
need information why does it need
to to have this information why does a
rock need
some sort of information image uh what
you call
information we as physicists
would just write as terms in equations
right we think of the physical world as
being driven by mathematical formulas
in these formulas there are what you
call degrees of freedom
so things can be this that or that
oxygen or halogen
right as an example all these things
should go on the equations
and we are used in particular in quantum
mechanics to the situation that if
two things start up differently they end
up differently
that's a fundamental notion in quantum
theory we can't get around that
you can't have two different states
adding up after a while to be the same
that is that violates the principles of
quantum mechanics
now quantum mechanics itself is not such
a sacred theory
that maybe there are violations of it
but then we want to know about this we
just don't want to say well you know we
have to clear that mess up later no no
the mess has to be cleared up right now
if there's a flaw of this sort in our
results we want to know about it
so what jorge was saying two different
black holes start out differently
in one of them a teapot is falling all
the other an old shoe i saw
this movie and if the teapot falls into
a black hole or an old shoe falls into a
black hole that's different
people's not the same thing as a shoe
nevertheless after a while they look
exactly the same according to him i see
so it has to be said
that's that violates our equations that
cannot be told there's something
wrong something went wrong on the way
and we want to know what it is thanks
for referring to that because i can't
tell you how hard it was to get the
teapot in the black hole and then
to get the shoe you know
just get get the teapot we said well you
got to get the shoe too and that was
really hard hermione please all right
okay let me first follow up on on sort
of the
because you were asking how was it to
have this debate with hawking that was
kind of your question
maybe we can tell an a little anecdote
about how it was in part it was of
course
all about science and we're all friends
even if we disagree about the science
but hawking is a
very special person where he can think
very deeply about questions
but he also has a handicap he cannot
speak so he has to speak with this
by typing words and then sometimes the
debate would go like this then
an argument would be given and then
hawking's response would be one word
rubbish
very hard to argue and that's very hard
to hockey accurate yeah and you know
you know and when i when i say rubbish
nobody pays any attention
you know but when hawking says rubbish
it's
yeah it's silent and you've lost the
argument at that point
capital r it's a big font
there yeah right when hawking says it
all right so
hawking says rubbish to you do you like
go home and tell your wife
hawking said rubbish to me what do i do
or do you like go to the blackboard or
you sit down at the computer what
happens
you you go on with because you believe
in your argument
the other question about information the
thing that i like sort of as a way of
uh explaining what information is we
live right now in the
in the age of information this is the
information age
and um but the type of information that
we're talking about here you say well
it's more complicated but one way of
imagining what kind of information we're
talking about is i like again
the movie the matrix where again there's
this virtual reality
where and actually i had kind of
nightmares for myself
when i was young okay well what if the
whole world is just
an a thing that's being projected on my
brain
or actually for all of us if we're
sitting here in this room and who knows
maybe it's just a computer that makes us
believe that we're real
and the kind of information that we're
talking about is really sort of what
what is inside of this computer imagine
you make the
this hall here with all the reality
of being able to do experiments things
fall
uh you collide things things happen
exactly the way we thought think about
them as happening in physics
but it's all just zeros and ones in a
computer
and in principle you can quantify how
many terabytes how many gigabytes how
many
i'm not sure if i forgot what comes
after gigabytes but there
there's information in that computer and
that's the kind of information that
we're
talking about so so when you say
information you say that
physicists believe and cosmologists
believe that it is possible to
map every aspect of reality that we are
experiencing here
into some sort of
stored code that specifies precisely
everything that's happening here what
people smell like
who is mad at who who who's wearing like
dirty shoes
and uh and and what they're even
thinking about
right you can imagine that that's the
way it goes
now just is that something scientists
are imagining
or does quantum mechanics insist
that that must be so raphael
uh quantum mechanics um in a way
is based on information it's a theory of
information
uh the way that we would describe the
world you know the room being
uh full of people or not full of people
and electron being in this place or in
that place uh
they these are different states as we
call them
and um it's it's as if you know you put
one letter on the page or you put a
different letter on the page it's a diff
it you know it conveys information um so
where a particle is
is a way of of of conveying information
and in fact quite literally when we
write something on a page we put
particles in particular places
um and we we thereby convey information
it's not very efficient
um comparison let's explore that for a
moment victoria do you have
rafael's slides put up his uh first
slide here because as a
as someone who studied mathematics
poorly um the understanding that i had
was that
as you go say say you're looking at the
coastline of
of of uh massachusetts and you're
looking at it from a satellite
and you you you see one line but then
you come closer and then you begin to
trace
every little indentation and then you
even get closer and you trace even
any more indeed and try to specify down
to the
atomic level that the amount of
information in the line that traces the
coastline
is actually unbounded and infinite um
what is it that you've discovered well
that it's not it's not infinite
there's a limit um and so how do we
embed this picture i i think there's one
important thing that maybe we need to
say in order to get from the black holes
to this
sure um i i was actually not part of
this debate with hawking i became
his student two years later um but
you look younger as a result as a result
yeah it's certainly
certainly aged these gentlemen here so i
i
i i i i i the reason we're ordered this
way
is we came in we figured raphael could
walk the furthest
right and uh we decided we're just going
to leave you here when we
yeah and hawking couldn't be here so you
got me you know
yeah yeah yeah he was here last year
yeah um anyway
so so so these gentlemen had you know
the crazy insight that um
when when information is dropped into a
black hole it is not in fact lost even
though naively you would just think okay
now it's in this black hole it's
somewhere but we can't get to it
they insisted that you still have to be
able to get to it which you know
lenny made it sound so easy but it
wasn't that obvious it was an incredible
intuition
and um and for that to be true for that
to be true that if you throw a phone
book into a black hole
that later on you can figure out whether
it was the new york or chicago phone
book
two amazing things have to happen uh
first of all hawking had to be wrong
about about the idea that that no matter
what you throw into the black hole the
same thing comes out
it's a very loose way of putting what he
said but that's the that's the basic way
information would be lost
um a second amazing thing had to happen
which is you know it takes a long time
for a black hole to fizzle away and
disappear and return
potentially return information to you
supposing hawking is wrong
and in the meantime you've got this big
fat black hole sitting there
and what had to be true was that while
the big fat black hole is sitting there
that that black hole
itself contains information while it's
still sitting there and hasn't fizzled
away yet
all right so that to be true there had
to be a limit on how much information
there could possibly be
in the region that was occupied by the
black hole because you could presumably
always convert that region into a black
hole
all right so let's let's back up for a
second um so so hawking
suggests that the information is gone
uh you say that can't possibly be true
hawking says rubbish and then you go
about saying well no we're going to find
where that information actually is
leonard
where and before we get to uh rafael's
slide here
um where did you find or where did
we find that that information that
hawking says is gone in the black hole
is actually stored
okay so one of the things that we found
is i'm sorry to say this john but that
turned out to be a bad
question okay that in a certain sense
bits of information don't necessarily
have locations
or at least they don't necessarily have
locations
which are objective and the same for
everybody no matter how they're moving
okay i'm all about questions the notion
of a bit of information
is a good one we believe it we believe
distinctions exist and distinctions
persist but the notion of where that bit
of
information is located turned out not to
be
a good what a physicist would call
invariant
question it might depend on who was
looking at it
now let me give you an example of where
it is a good idea if an
atom decays inside the sun
everybody will agree it happened inside
the sun
it doesn't matter if you're moving
relative to the sun it doesn't matter if
you're
far away if you're nearby everybody will
agree if they do the calculation they
see what comes out they'll agree
the atom decayed inside the sun if the
thing
happened inside the sun black holes are
different
and what we found out is the whole
notion of whether something happens
inside a black hole or if it happens
just above the surface of the black hole
surface meaning the horizon is a
question which is observer dependent
somebody who falls into the black hole
may have all of the experiences of
seeing the event happen
well in past the horizon somebody
standing outside the black hole
will reconstruct out of the hawking
radiation
that that event actually happened
outside the black hole
so the answer to your question is we
didn't find out where the information
was
we found out that it was an improper
question
that bits of information don't really
have
locations in that sense and how do you
know they weren't destroyed if you
couldn't
find them in a particular location well
eventually
eventually a lot of the power of string
theory and other mathematics
came to bear on it and confirmed that
there was no expectation that it would
be destroyed
but as can i call you gerard it's so
much
easier okay as my friend georgia says
i spent years learning to say harad but
never mind
i'm totally fine with her art yeah
totally fine with it
god i'm 70 years old 71 years old and i
forgot what i was going to say
um no no but you you were you you were
saying
that uh the the issue of
where it was and the invariance of of of
the question meant that
or the the the variance of my question
meant that you know you wanted to
basically
change the nature of the inquiry yeah
right but you asked me how we know
and i think the answer was given by
gerard
that so much would break down in physics
the whole structure of everything we
know about physics would break down and
disintegrate
if even you open the door a tiny little
bit for the idea of information to be
lost
once it can be lost you can promote that
and make it worse and worse and worse
and worse
and eventually the whole structure of
physics as we know it will break down
there are some things you can't have a
little bit of you either have it or you
don't you know we all know about
pregnancy but uh
but let me give you another example in
mathematics
can you have a theory a theory which
means a mathematical structure
arithmetic or whatever can you have a
theory which is approximately consistent
it's almost completely consistent okay
well you might have some structure some
set of axioms
and you derive you you let your computer
run and derive
10 000 theorems from it and it
say oh it's approximately consistent
only four of them were inconsistent with
each other
well no a mathematician would come and
tell you once you have any inconsistency
you can use that inconsistency to
promote
promote it anything is inconsistent with
everything else basically
i think the same thing was true about
information loss
once you had it once you had it in any
form at all
you could imagine situations where it
would undermine
basically all of physics and that's what
uh i think that's what gerard thought
that's what i thought
and it's what stephen didn't think so we
sort of battled
our heads against the wall for a while
all right so how in my imperfect uh
question creating way can can we get to
the point of
either if not where was the information
how did we
learn conclusively that it wasn't
destroyed and that
if the phone book went into the
singularity
that uh there was a way to find out if
it was chicago or
amsterdam or you know
soweto whenever i encounter a situation
like this
i try to approach it from all possible
angles
particularly angles that my neighbors
here would not be prepared to look at
to see what can be done we have as i
said a paradox here
and the resolution must come from a
totally different
point of view than previously now one
thing was
that quantum mechanics was used to
derive a result that quantum mechanics
somehow
failed to be to agree with the
pythagorean or something wrong
so my attitude was we start from the
other hand now let's assume that the
black hole
as a whole agrees with every anything we
know about quantum mechanics
that means information in is equal to
information
out it's that simple basically in
important mechanical sense
so that ought to be true as soon as you
believe that this is true it's a
relatively simple calculation to find
how much
information there is in the black hole
and you do the calculation you find the
amount of information in the black hole
is exactly equal
to its surface area it's like putting
bits and bytes of a computer memory on
the surface
every bit every byte of information
occupies very precise amount of surface
which you can
calculate relatively easily and that
tells you big black holes contain lots
of information small ones contain a
little information still
enormous amounts in any absolute sense
but
that was a very clear conclusion how
much information there is in the black
hole
but the question where the information
is is something else
again all right but let me just back up
here
so so all you got
if you got your black hole to study at
least not to find where the information
is but to
to figure out if there is a
a quantity of information that could be
sufficient
to specify what goes on in this black
hole you've got yourself just sufficient
the exact quantity itself
exactly okay there's a few bits hanging
around the side but
apart from that the total quantity of
information
is very precisely calculable but you but
but all you've got is the surface of the
black hole
and and and so you've got to test could
there be enough information
on the surface to specify what's gone
into the singularity and what's
happening beyond this event horizon
that's the question right well
the question was answered by this
assumption that the black hole should
obey quantum mechanics once you make
that assumption
you find that not only the information
of things that went in and out the black
hole
but everything is in its vicinity should
be mapped onto its surface
in bits and bytes it's like saying that
the surface is a hologram
of the immediate surrounding space time
so a a x
dimensional object can specify an
x plus one dimensional object yeah are
you getting that
is this working for you we're cool right
all right all right good
you're all with us okay so the surface
is two-dimensional
so surface space time is
three-dimensional which is exactly what
a hologram does you got your
two-dimensional star wars movie and your
three-dimensional looking princess leia
who by the way did have a prom date i
believe uh
and and and so is but is that an
illusion
you know in perspective it's basically
you're creating an illusion
or is it actually a one-to-one mapping
of all the information
of the reality onto the 2d surface
that gives you your 3d reality herman
yeah again talking about the mapping
then we don't know exactly how that
mapping works at this point
but i would say that the thing the
principle that turns out to be very
powerful in this context i call it the
rumsfeld principle
and and it's basically saying well it's
better to deal with
known unknowns than with unknown
unknowns
so so he was bad at all of them but yeah
right yeah
so so the the the unknown unknowns are
stuff that you lose and you don't know
that you lost it
uh if you throw something in a black
hole for all practical purses
purposes you've lost it you've lost the
information
but what we're talking about is actually
that i that we know that we lost it
again i don't remember what i ate for
breakfast yesterday but i
i knew i had breakfast so at least i
know how much information i lost
by having a bad memory and
so so the fact that we could quantify
how much
information is in the black hole and
that it's measured by the area
that turned out to be the surprisingly
the
the key insight so knowing how to
quantify what you don't know
uh is is a deep is a deep principle
all right i think yeah that that's
actually starting to work for me let's
let's forget your slides raphael for the
moment if you don't mind
and go to leonard's slide which really
gets us from this idea
of there's a bunch of information and it
maps
into something that we might think of as
a three-dimensional image victoria can
you put
leonard's first slide up okay what is
this one
uh that's a microscopic picture of
the film of a hologram which in fact
i made up myself with a microsoft paint
so it's a fake but it's about what it
would look like it's about what if you
look
through the microscope at the film not
this thing that
is being described by the hologram but
by the piece of film itself
it would look approximately like that
and so then if you
put light through it in some particular
way well let's let's
first it's got some information in it
it's all scrambled it's impossibly
scrambled you can't look at this
and see what the what it is anybody any
guesses what the the
image is there anybody want to guess
what leonard susskind
donald trump okay
great so it is a fake anyone say puppy
anyone say probably a little horsey
no no horses okay all right let's see
well okay go through the next one
let's go to the next one here's here's
the stand by folks all right
this is another fake i also drew that
myself all right all right so if you do
the right
thing with the hologram namely shine
light on it and so forth
it'll reconstruct an image so the the
the you got the flashlight
uh yeah yeah maybe this is obvious but
flashlight going through the film
and somehow the the information
in the film recreates the 3d image of
the clown smoking the cigar
right but the interesting thing about it
is that the clown is three-dimensional
you can go behind it and you can see
whether he has hair on the back of his
head
you can go underneath and look at the
chin underneath in fact
if this hologram had been made not with
ordinary light but if it'd been made by
an nmr scan you could have
coded on that boundary on that surface
you could have the interior you could
have all your guts and blood and
everything else bones
the entire full three-dimensional
structure
would have been mapped you used the word
map and it's a good word
mapped onto the boundary onto the film
uh and the important thing is not that
you shine light to reconstruct it
but that the information about the clown
is equally well and in fact in some
sense better described
more accurately described more precisely
described
by the little dots and dashes and
structures
that are entirely scrambled totally
impossible for you to just look at
but it's there it's there in that film
there and and
as you say you can add detail to that
informational film infinitely or
is there an upper limit okay so in the
world that we're talking about which is
the real world
there's a limit no more than one
bit that means a plus or minus one
little dot
per plunk area the planck area is a
certain unit of
area that's made up out of the
fundamental constants of nature
it happens to be about 10 to the minus
33 centimeters on a side it's far
smaller than anything that physics
studies experimentally
but no more let it go it disappeared
uh okay black hole i had something they
went in the black hole
yeah no more than one bit that means a
black dot or a white
white dot per plunk area
all right so let's just back that up for
a second um just
as you need a certain amount of
resolution on a piece of standard film
or a digital ccd chip
to produce an image that's recognizable
of your
lovely pets or your kids or something
like that uh
in physics one bit of information is it
a traditional bit
as though yes it's a yes or no question
yes or no questions
zero one bit yeah zero one is is
necessary
to specify a planck space which is an
infinitesimal but measurable a little
chunk of space well beyond our
ability to measure at the present but
yes aye
and so what it says i mean in in essence
what it says
is this entire room everything that's in
it
can be in principle described
mathematically
in terms of degrees of freedom
structures on the boundaries on the
walls of the room
with never needing more than one bit of
information per plunk area
that was very radical that was very
surprising because people had always
associated
information with volume we have another
picture but uh
maybe you want to go around well let's
go no let's let's go to uh this is the
pixel
the pixels and the voxels okay let's do
the uh pixel voxels that's the next two
slides so we're trying to come up first
first the uh pixels all right this is
obviously a two d
can we jump can we jump to the other one
first all right let's do the voxels
first okay
all right there's the room if you like
there's the room
and i'm going to describe the room
everything that's in the room
by dividing it up into little tiny cells
a cell let's say no bigger than atom and
what can we ask about a cell we can ask
is there or isn't there an atom in it of
course we can ask what type of atom but
let's ignore that
is there isn't there an atom in it and
if we didn't have to worry about the
type of
atom that would be a complete
description of everything that's in the
room
and so there would be one decision for
each voxel a voxel is a word that means
a little cube
there would be one bit of information
per voxel it's either
empty or it's full all right so we've
divided up this room
uh in in each plank
well i i was talking about atoms but yes
all right in each
bigger than a plank space that we've
decided to choose right we're asking the
question
is there an atom in there and there's a
yes or no answer to that and we
reconstruct the entire space in
information terms in a cube like this
right
and we got some place there are atoms
some place there's not i would say in
this room would probably be a lot of
yeses
probably right many more no's and yeses
you think
oh that's right space is mostly empty
yeah the room is almost all empty space
always it annoys me to hear that always
but yeah
anyway okay so so now now that's the
3d yeah so what's the other picture well
what we found
in essence is that's too much
information
no room can ever have as much
information as is
implicit in this picture here the amount
of information that it takes to describe
the room is more like
this picture here one bit of information
plur per surface area so i like to say
the world is pixelated not vaccinated
the world is made up or the degrees of
freedom of the world the most
accurate description we can ever have is
in terms of a number of degrees of
freedom
which is proportional to the area and
not the volume so it's actually the
reverse of our intuition and
help me out here so we like to think of
gosh you know movies are great but
wouldn't it be
fabulous to to have imax 3d in fact what
physics says is
you can get all the information in your
3d
high-res reality world on a 2d surface
let me just
one thing before i want to get these
guys yeah the only
thing is that the two-dimensional
description is going to be monstrously
scrambled
very difficult to decode very difficult
to see what it's a picture of
that's the that's the cost of coding
information in two dimensions
instead of three right
as a mathematician your first reaction
will be
there's much less space on a
two-dimensional surface than in a
three-dimensional world
so the first reaction is that can't be
right we will be missing
enormous amounts of information if we
try to put scramble everything on the
surface
however you have to remember that this
is the planck length which is
extremely small to for all standards
10 to the minus 33 centimeters is
extremely tiny even
in units of elementary particles so even
this
looks at first side to be very little
information actually it is
enormous it's gigantic but on the other
hand you have to realize
that not only what's in this room should
be mapped on the surface
but the entire universe can be mapped on
the surface
that's even more gigantically
crazy because you would think that
the surface of the universe would be
much smaller than its volume
but again these plank units are so small
that
still you have enough information on the
surface
to specify everything that goes on in
the universe
well it i mean it's so counterintuitive
i mean every time i go into the holland
tunnel i wonder how
all of new york could fit in here but in
fact that's kind of what you're
saying um so it is very very
counterintuitive so
so you you you come up with these
mathematical
conclusions that are very robust and
sound and you can defend them
i mean do you go back herman to hawking
and then does he say
sorry about saying rubbish or i guess i
was wrong about the rubbish
credit he has started changing at least
his opinion
and he accepts a lot of these ideas um
einstein for example had a much harder
time accepting quantum mechanics i don't
think he ever did
but hawking uh i think he he realized at
the time when he was
proposing he was putting this paradox
forward
that by by stating
the the contradiction that was in in
black hole physics
he realized that that was a way of
making uh progress
uh and of course he liked annoying his
colleagues which is sort of what he was
doing by
making this particular claim but he put
us to work
so and then by the time that that
answers came came forward he
he has so he had this bet with one of
his colleagues
that i think it was for a year-long
subscription to playboy
but in the end the colleague decided to
give him a a nice book
instead because the bat the bat was
settled
and then hawking admitted that
that information was there and
so that's well the the whole 2d 3d thing
if you bring playboy into it as a whole
i don't that's a whole other information
space
i don't even want to think about um as a
as a much younger researcher
raphael what excites you about the
holographic principle in terms of
and we're going to get into its
controversy in a moment in terms of what
it begins to
explain about other problems in physics
i think what's exciting to me is that um
the only way that information could
possibly
not be lost when a black hole forms and
then evaporates
was for there to be a completely
universal
relation between the information content
of a region
and its surface area in other words
there was a relation between
surfaces in space time which are
described by gravity theory it's
that's the realm of einstein's general
relativity
surfaces surrounding certain regions
those surfaces
their area specified how much
information could be
in the region that was enclosed by them
that turned out to be not quite the
right way of stating it but that was
that was necessary if uh information was
not going to be lost in black holes
in other words it led to a statement
about how much information there is in
the world
that was completely independent of what
you were using to encode the information
it didn't matter whether you used
letters on a page or or
or atoms or strings or quarks whatever
your favorite
uh physical ingredient was it was a
statement that was completely universal
if information was preserved then we
were learning something
about fundamentally how much information
there is in the world
well even beyond that let me just maybe
say one thing
just to put it in a class it's actually
not very difficult to understand why
this
is so very roughly speaking any place
like this room
can be converted by crashing some shells
of matter into it
uh into a black hole that has the same
surface area as this room
and we know how much information the
black hole contains so
if information is not lost that means
that the information in this room no
matter what was in here
had to be less to start with than the
information of the black hole or at most
equally much
and so it's completely universal you
don't have to know what we're made out
of you don't have to know what the
fundamental
bits and pieces of physics are you
already know how much information there
is
and so it's a deep relation between the
two things that we don't know how to put
together
gravity and quantum mechanics quantum
mechanics is about information gravity
is about
geometry and surfaces but is it is it
true
or is it uh a distortion to say
and again for me for a moment here the
idea of going to the black hole
seems to confuse the issue because the
the black hole is interesting because
the way hawking described it information
would be destroyed
that produces the controversy which
poses the question all right what is the
relationship between information
and all of the universes that's exactly
right it's exactly right it was it was
one of those questions where
you know people were just asking an
incredibly interesting question
and as a consequence of resolving it
stumbled upon something that was much
more general
and didn't really just hold in this
particular context of the black hole
in the end you can throw the black hole
away because i think most of the people
in this room you know
the encounters with black holes are you
know monthly at best
um so so so let's just let's just say
because of the black hole thought
experiment
uh controversy argument with hawking
we have stumbled upon or discovered or
now see that a fundamental
feature of the universe is that a
a two-dimensional space of information
specifies everything in our universe
well something like that initially it
was to be clear how to apply this to the
whole universe
um again the context in which this was
discovered was a very specific one
where you're far away you throw some
elephants in into a small region they
form a black hole and it evaporates
and you want to ask the question by
looking at this hawking radiation that
came out can i figure out if it was
elephants or zebras that made the black
hole
now that was resolved i think by now
pretty definitely
we can look at this but our universe is
nothing like that our universe is not
like the
like a black hole our universe is not um
a place where you can go far away and
study hawking radiation coming out
and nevertheless it turned out to be
true that
that this was just the tip of an iceberg
there's a completely universal relation
between information and area of surfaces
at first it seems like that can't
possibly be true
for example if you don't take the
viewpoint of the person who waits for
the hawking radiation to fizzle out of
the black hole and then looks carefully
at
at the information that is in it suppose
that i fell in with the elephants or
with a star that was collapsing
well that star has some information in
it as it's collapsing to form a black
hole that information can't disappear
but we know from just solving the
einstein's equations that the surface
area of the star
becomes smaller and smaller and smaller
until it's zero
at the very end when it's when it's when
it hits the singularity inside a black
hole
so it seems clear that the amount of
information
of the star whatever it is at some point
is going to become larger than this
smaller and smaller and smaller surface
area of the stars it gets more
compressed deep inside the black hole
so then does this mean that this was
just some fluke it's something that
applies to particular
you know observers who live far outside
the black hole and there's actually no
general relation between
information and surface areas well turns
out no
if you state the relation in just the
right way
then it's true even deep inside a black
hole or in
in regions of the universe that are very
large and the way you have to state it
is actually in a much more physical way
instead of saying
how much information do i have at this
instant of time when my star is really
small
and has very small surface area how much
information is there still inside the
star
you you have to ask well if i took a
picture of that of that star
at this time just before it got
completely crunched into
into a singular a place in space time
if i took a picture of it how much of
the star would i see
and it turns out that you don't have
enough time
you're the light doesn't have enough
time to traverse the whole star
before everything gets crunched into the
singularity and the game is over
you have to actually calculate this you
have to take my word for it right now
but i'm taking your word for so much
but the point is if you ask okay what
can what can actual light rays see how
much information can they see
light rays that come out of the area in
question and it makes absolutely no
difference what area you pick anywhere
in the universe any shape doesn't even
have to be closed
um what those light rays see
is some piece of the star in this
particular example and by some
conspiratorial miracle it's always less
information in that piece of the star
than the surface area you started from
it it's a much bigger conspiracy of
which only the sort of
tip of the iceberg was was was
discovered in the context of it's a
little bit like
uh uncertainty in the sense that if you
try to measure you're only going to get
a piece of it but that doesn't affect
the the the existence of all the
information
it's it's all there the fact that you
can't get it or don't have a big enough
camera
is your own personal psychological
problem it doesn't affect the universe
at all
well indeed if you if you wanted to ask
how much information is there in the
universe
then again it's actually very useful
that information is sort of encoded on
on
regions that are seen by light rays you
could just ask well
what is in our past what is in the
region from which light could have
reached us up until now
and that that region is bounded by
basically light rays that are just
barely making it to your eyes right now
and they've been traveling for billions
of years since the beginning of the
universe
and those light rays well if you follow
them back
of course they come from a larger and
larger region as you follow them back
that's farther and farther away
but at some point their surface area
actually becomes very small again when
when you follow them all the way back to
the big bang because everything is small
at the big bang
the universe is basically contracting to
a single point at that at that point
and so there's a largest area which
tells you how much information there is
in the universe somewhere between
the big bang and us that is spanned by
these light rays
so so we can say exactly what the
maximum amount of information
is it is the case on some level that the
function of our senses i mean
you know galileo looked at light rays
and drove some conclusion about the
universe
are tiny sort of instances of the
universe conveying
in information something that's much
bigger that
you're now extrapolating to extreme
states of the universe either in terms
of the very beginning of time with the
big bang or
the sort of end of matter in a black
hole that they're part of the same story
a little bit
well the interesting thing about the
holographic principle i think
i think all of us probably agree on this
is that it's a statement that can be
made
in a situation where we think under we
understand physics very well
uh the the area that describes how much
information there is in the universe
that we see is not an area that lives
somewhere very close to the big bang
where we might not trust our equations
the area that tells us how much
information there is inside a black hole
is not an area that's somehow close to
the singularity inside the black hole
which we don't understand as well as we
would like to
these are areas in regions of space time
that are arbitrarily well understood
they're completely harmless
they're you know we einstein's theory of
this is good harmless is always good
i mean i still wouldn't jump into the
black hole but right
they are very you know well understood
the whole
statement takes place in a regime of
physics that we completely understand
but what we don't understand ultimately
is why it is
true it seems like a conspiracy every
time you check it works out
and and i think that by itself i think
it was always a huge
piece of support for the idea that
information isn't lost all these
miracles happen
for information not to get lost it'd be
funny if it was at the end
but but you have to do it in a case
i mean your sense of humor is not so i
know yeah right well i love apocalypses
like the next guy but uh
um so uh herman what what is the counter
argument
here what i mean i've got sort of two
questions one is
what is the counter argument who
persists with the idea that this
holographic principle may
be fun to talk about but in fact doesn't
really help us uh or there's another
explanation
uh i wouldn't necessarily say that maybe
that people have uh
a counter-argument but right now you can
state it as a principle because we have
indications that it's there
but again it's it's basically a from a
from
still from intuitive point of view it's
absurd
that this would be true uh because again
if we want to describe what's going on
for sure we're going to
tell okay well something is happening
here at a given time
or something's happening there so
essentially the information that you use
to describe
things for sure grows with the volume
and indeed the equations that we're
using uh to describe physics
indeed have all those properties
so right now we don't have a real uh
real
way of understanding how this is really
true
so we know we have no there's no
evidence
no we don't have a mathematical theory
that precisely describes how it is we
have
strong evidence that it's true and i
think i think so there were early times
say in the early 90s
uh where uh if you would and i think
there was a
conference in the early 90s where there
was a vote
okay how many people were actually
believing that information was lost and
then
more than half of the hands went up and
it was only a small group of
uh people that were saying okay well we
we don't believe that information is
lost and that was only a couple of
rubbish groups
there was the yeah there was the rubbish
group and then there was yeah okay right
and now the rubbish group is bigger uh
almost the whole room
yeah if you call us the rubbish group
well you were then
you were then yeah we were called
rubbish yeah yeah that's correct
and um probably so how um
i want to go back to this information i
actually want you to go through those
slides
that i've seen before which i think are
fascinating but uh
let me ask you um is information
up a particle in the sense that it's
like matter is information akin to
being like electrons protons quarks
antimatter is it some sort of parallel
phenomenon that goes along with the
reality or is it something fundamentally
different
no actually i think it's about time that
we start to disagree with each other
and um no so i want to know
um starting to get good because
i want to bring in a notion which hasn't
been put forward yet
the question of dynamics you know when i
first
saw people windsurfing i loved also to
go windsurfing
so on one day i thought i'm a
theoretical physicist
i can work out how to stand on the board
i have to hold the sale
without falling over and i worked it all
out
and i stood on the board i could hand
the sail and i didn't fall over
and i went any direction i want except i
only solved the static problem
i didn't solve the problem what happens
if a big wave comes
and what what what you have to do if you
want to make a sudden turn
this i never saw so whenever that
happens i fall over
now here the problem is the same so far
we've been discussing this static
question what is information where is it
and so on and you can discuss it at
length
but there's something else in physics
the dynamical question
how do things evolve in time and
how do we phrase laws of nature and now
we encounter a
deep and fundamental problem which is
the world looks to us
three-dimensional if i make a
disturbance here
like i'm saying something or i'm shining
a light the disturbance moves with the
speed of light or slower
to its environment and it never goes
faster than speed of light from here to
a point far away in the universe
that is a fundamental three-dimensional
property of the world as we know
and it has been tested very very
accurately in all branches of physics
a very fundamental principle not only
that disturbances move
there's a certain maximum speed it also
has causality
that is whenever you cause some
disturbance somewhere
its effect never goes faster than the
speed of light
and it certainly doesn't go back in time
now this principle we would like to keep
and now holography is standing in our
way
it's not doing the thing we want if my
friend landing here is right
and information on the three-dimensional
on the two-dimensional surface is
completely scrambled
how do you explain it if you make a
disturbance here the disturbance doesn't
spread faster than speed of light
how would leah when she moves her arms
uh in the hologram how come that
the disturbances don't move faster than
a given speed in his hologram
there's still something basically wrong
with the idea
and that why would they have to move
faster than the speed of light to uh
to work that's relativity theory and
relativity theory works
extremely well we don't want to give
that up
too easily as a fundamental principle
after all relativity was
also a principle that went into steve
hawkins
derivation if you throw it away you saw
you're throwing away black holes as well
so life isn't that easy there's a
problem here
so how do we address that and then
i'm coming back to quantum mechanics we
say
well we use quantum mechanics from the
beginning until the end
there's something not quite right about
quantum mechanics
and i've been thinking a lot last
decades basically about there must be
something
underneath quantum mechanics some more
basic
mechanical system that explains why the
world that we encounter today looks like
quantum mechanical
that could solve this problem because it
could be that in a
pre-quantum world the world is
three-dimensional
information gets lost all the time in
fact
a suspicion i have and i'm practically
the only one in the universe today
that has a suspicion that there's an
underlying theory
in which information gets lost to such
an extent
that if you have a bulk of material
somewhere
so much information gets lost that the
only thing that you can retain is what
sits on the surface
and that is the reason why
information-wise you have such a thing
as a holographic principle
the only amount of information that you
can keep if you have a bucket of water
is what sits on the edge of the bucket
of water what happens inside will
eventually get lost not according to
quantum theory because it just realized
all
quantum theory preserves information but
there may be a pre-quantum theory
in which this information gets lost now
is this
it could be three-dimensional and then
we might possibly
find a resolution of this problem so is
is
pre-quantum theory something that
happened
before the big bang or is pre-quantum
theory something that happens before you
learn
in the logical sense that there is
something
that some fundamental principle lying
underneath
so the principle of quantum mechanics i
see saying
we have molecules you have atoms we have
things smaller than atoms
but smaller than that are things which
might not be quantum mechanical
that is my premature explanation as to
how to reconcile
the idea that the three-dimensional
world seems to be two-dimensional
by holographic principle yet there is
causality in the three-dimensional sense
this is a problem that has not yet been
properly addressed
and i think something should be done
about this if we don't
yeah we'll never get to work if we don't
right if you don't you'll forget
homelessness you guys
from times small distances well let's
let's uh put that to leonard um
is there the possibility of a a pre
you know a more axiomatic kind of uh
quantity all right but then some sort of
more basic
state than quantum mechanics the answer
is i don't know the answer is i don't
know
what you're seeing here is an
interesting thing
first of all i would say it should be
clear
that this whole holographic story is the
most radical thing that has happened to
our understanding
of space time matter since
the invention of quantum mechanics and
relativity it is really something very
very different
where is it going what is it going to
explain
how do we explain it well incidentally
we all agree
largely on what we've said until now
and you'll find that in physics in
general probably in science in general
at any given time there are those things
which have been made into established
science that people agree on
and that subset they will tend to agree
on unless they're screwballs and outside
the main
mainstream of the community but that
once you go past that
once you go even just a little bit past
what we really know
you'll start finding it becoming a very
very human subject
a subject with uh let's put it this way
good physicists
are as variable as snowflakes every
single one of them is different every
single one of them has a different
perspective
and once you go past that point
where we have confirmation where we do
agree
you're going to find that just about
everybody has a different view of where
it's going to go sure without that i can
understand but
let's focus on the radicalism for a
moment because i think people can
understand how relativity
radically changed the newtonian view of
reality in the sense that
the straight lines in the newtonian
world actually
are curved in certain spaces and that
curvature
relates to the force of gravity in some
way and so around stars space actually
bends
that's a radical notion it's probably
only in the last 30 years that that's
been internalized to be something that
kind of everybody understands you can't
really appreciate
matrix movies like the matrix unless you
sort of understand the sort of
relativistic world
how does this notion
produce a radical change
in in the way that we might see
relativity
i think it's still a work in progress
and we don't know
harad has his view
i have my view herman has his view
what's his name over there has his view
and but i tell you if you go out of this
it'll come to you
but you go two blocks outside of this
room there's a lot of people who have no
view
and a lot of people have no reason yeah
absolutely no of you but my own view
is not all that different than my
colleague over here
it's not that i think there's going to
be some deterministic theory that's
going to underlie quantum mechanics
i think it is is going to inform how we
think about quantum mechanics very
deeply
and it's going to change in an
enormously big way the way that we think
about quantum mechanics
that i am sure of whether it will be the
way
that uh that raphael and i have proposed
over the last couple of weeks or the way
that
uh hoofter has proposed for years uh
herman has his ideas i think that
remains to be seen and it is a work in
progress
i think there will be progress on it i
think when we come back here maybe not
next year but five years from now
there will be more knowledge but
it's very clear we're on the cutting
edge of
and on the cusp of i think a major
paradigm shift in the way the world
right all right that's great now uh uh
how are we doing we're feeling pretty
good about
holographic principle and projection
right right
and we're feeling pretty good about how
information is a much more complicated
thing than
maybe the the concept from our intuition
right right
okay good all right here's a question
that's going to put you on the spot
um but it relates to your issue of the
each of you think differently the
physicists are
as different to snowflakes and hopefully
they stick around longer than snowflakes
if if i were to put a holographic
principle t-shirt on each one of you
that specified
how each one of you represents a
particular sense of
what's going to happen what we're going
to discover what aspect that represents
your position
what would your t-shirt say i believe in
holographic principle
and it's going to look like blank i
i don't know i would like have something
like i heart hp or something
well i that's going to be on the back
that the front is going to have to
take you to quantum gravity on the back
so
your ticket to quantum gravity so i mean
why do we call it a principle
like you know i think the positive
spin the most positive spin i can try to
put on this and i am being optimistic
when i say this is
is um compare this to the equivalence
principle
the equivalence principle is something
that einstein recognized you know a huge
conspiracy in nature why do all objects
fall at the same rate
you know different particles with
different charges do not do not get
attracted to each other at the same rate
but
with gravity for some reason everything
gets attracted in exactly the same way
amazing conspiracy from the point of
view of newtonian theory you just have
to put it in by hand
it doesn't contradict anything but it's
it's just crazy it needs an explanation
see elevates this observation to a
universal principle you have to find
a theory that makes this obvious to
start with so for you
that would have to be quantum gravity
because what's involved here is both
quantum theory
and general relativity it would have to
be a theory that knows about both
so it clearly is a signpost maybe we
need more signposts
to fight the right find the right for
you holographic principle is a suspect
is a
is a first step towards a a theory of
quantum gravity that begins to explain
what's so frustrating about gravity well
then indeed what it what
just said tells us why it's been so hard
you have to explain where this
holographic
bound on information comes from while
not destroying what we know about
locality the fact that i get to know in
this part of the room something
independent
independently of there i get to move
particles around independently it seems
like
you don't have to know what's over there
to do something here there seems to be a
conflict here between
holography and the way that physics has
worked up until right
on your t-shirt ramon what would it say
uh
i mentioned the movie the matrix
probably something some image
like these letters and and
there's nemo what's his name the guy who
he uh he goes and and he starts um
uh uh flying uh with anti-gravity i
think that's that's pretty good
so let me let me explain why the matrix
uh we talked about sort of
things not being able to to move faster
than the speed of light
and i think the people that came up with
the the name of the matrix actually had
something pretty good in mind there
because what is a matrix it's
essentially something that relates
something that's here with something
that's completely somewhere else
and um so i think indeed that sort of
the
the the future at least of this
development will be that we
start actually with information so
information is going to be our starting
point
and space time is not something that we
start with uh we
we forget about what space is and what
time
and then somehow the information by
thinking about
how much information is what information
is doing
then the space time will what we call be
emergent it will come out of
just a bunch of zeros and ones and
here's one one idea that i think
actually i can put here just since no
one's listening and i can just say what
i want they're listening i guarantee you
uh so so there's no non-disclosure yeah
so so here's so we talked about
information and
one of the things by the way that
information tends to do again it gets
lost all the time
actually that's that's this called the
second law of thermodynamics
uh the lost information we call it
entropy entropy always increases
chaos increases and that's that's a fact
that's true
in our universe and it's a fact that's
true in other universes as well so it's
a very fundamental fact of how things
work
and what's probably also true in other
universes is that things indeed fall
if you if you drop them they they'll go
down
and it seems that those two facts are
very closely related the fact that
information gets lost
uh all the time and the fact that things
fall
so uh i think that that's lost is
different from destroyed
lost when i say lost indeed it's it's
going to be the the known unknown
right so it's got it the increase in the
known unknowns
uh that's responsible for for for for
space-time for for curvature space-time
from for gravity
the fact that things i mean what you're
suggesting is that you know when i
forget
something i'm instead of just having a
kind of a pre-senility moment
i'm actually participating in a grand
march
of our understanding of the universe
right that's correct yeah that's correct
that's
i'm loving i'm glad i came tonight uh
gerard
what would be on your uh t-shirt or sign
that would suggest uh
where you fall on and i guess probably
the pre-quantum
theory uh uh uh the
the proto quantum theory might be on
your t-shirt that might be
the direction that you would be headed
yes i will
continue to ask nasty questions
and say well you know you could have
this fancy beautiful idea
but remember that there are fundamental
principles on which the original idea
was based
that you're losing out of sight and so
this was
why i mentioned causality uh the
fact of the author of cause and events
that is to me
a very primary law or
rule of nature that everything that
happens here
has its origin in the past that's what
we call causality there's a cause of
everything
happening in this world that's how laws
of nature
are being formulated if you don't have
that
you can friends go backward in time and
you have circular
situations in time like you can go and
kill your grandfather if you could move
back
in time that's clearly nonsense then you
get
circular arguments and you get chaos in
the laws of nature themselves
nature cannot solve its own equations
that cannot be right
we must have the principle of causality
now this is somewhat at odds with this
holographic principle i don't say it's
entirely at odds but there's some
tension here and what we want the whole
reason why we are doing this why we're
making this
all these considerations is that we want
to have a better
model a better theory of what happens in
the physical world we want to explain
why the particles that you have today
behave as we have seen and studied them
today
and there are many things you understand
the many things you don't understand
we have the standard model of elementary
particles is a
beautiful rigid scheme of all particles
known today
and it is mindfully precisely described
by this standard model
but there are mysteries in it which we
want to understand and solve
as well we are very ambitious we've made
a marvelous theory of nature it's not
good enough
we still know there are blank spots in
this theory that we want to fill in
and this is why we're doing this we want
to find new basic principles to improve
our understanding of nature that's what
all of this is about but the only way to
understand or
to improve our understanding of nature
is we're asking all sorts of nasty
questions
questions our colleagues you rather not
ask because there's
so confusing well let's ask confusing
questions
anyway and see if you can come close to
answering them
any question that has an unexpected
answer
might bring us help us go forward and
make an improved theory of the world
that we live in that's
what the real reason is for this
exercise and i love this idea that
possibly one way of thinking about
causality and
causality and the forward branch of time
is as a
information state as a as a sort of a a
an understanding of the march of time as
a
a set of information
that that you know one event leads to
another event that's
a vision that the universe is very much
like an information
processing machine just like your laptop
or any other computer i like to view
nature as a gigantically big computer
that has information going into it and
information comes out
processed the processors they are the
laws of nature the laws of nature says
say that something happens some
particular configuration goes in
it's being rearranged and other
combinations of data goes out
that's how in physics traditionally we
consider
the process of particles touching and
scattering against each other
but two parties come like this they hit
each other and they go off in the other
direction
that's because scattering and scattering
process is
an important way of describing the laws
of nature what happens when two
particles meet
how do they separate do they break each
other up
do new particles form and so on and so
forth so
that's a fundamental way of phrasing
laws of nature and
that's what we want to understand can i
ask you a question on this
so so again if we talk about pre-quantum
mechanics in quantum mechanics we know
that
at least one of the foundations of
physics
quantum mechanics has thrown it out of
the window because one of the
foundations of physics was
if you know what's happening at a
certain moment what the situation is at
a certain time
that one step later in time you would
know what happens next
but in quantum mechanics you can have
two completely identical situations
that a snap snap second later
would give you two different outcomes
that as well
uh is that a principle that you accept
or is your pre-quantum mechanics going
to be
of the title i accept entirely within
the language of quantum mechanics but
my suspicion is it's only a suspicion is
that quantum mechanics cannot be the
entire story
there is something else happening and
you're
exactly asking the right question which
is how come that if two particles
reach each other and in the beginning
they were identically the same
and then suddenly they must do either
this or they might do that
or other particles might come out and
all that
is described by a matrix in fact in the
quantum mechanical
sense and but nobody knows how to
predict
what which of the possibilities is
actually being realized
that i think is a weak spot in our
present understanding of quantum
mechanics
why is it impossible to predict in
advance what will happen
and there are numerous examples of this
which are typical for quantum mechanics
and physicists today have learned to
ignore
the problem to say we solve everything
except we cannot always predict exactly
what happens what we can say
is that you need all the possibilities
to compute what happens after that
so that that's a mysterious feature of
quantum mechanics and you want to
embrace
the mystery rather than ignore they
exactly
a little bit okay they've learned to do
that because it is so successful
it works tremendously well in
understanding nature
but it cannot to my taste it cannot be
the entire story
there's something else happening but at
a different
level of nature and my belief is the
quant the
planck scale is so much different from
the scale of elementary particles
that that could well be the level at
which things are fundamentally different
there you have if two things scatter
they have only one choice to make
not many very many that's the idea of
determinism
which people laugh at when i mention
this idea
people just manage to keep the smile
away from their faces but otherwise
you know as soon as i'm away i'm sure
they're laughing about this
idea of determinism well we can check
some of the comments on the website
later crazy but
it's an old idea it's an old idea and it
has proven wrong about a million times
and but always they prove wrong because
they're making very conservative
assumptions and
i don't believe those assumptions so i
still think there's a way
to question it very very difficult and
it's a dispute
going on for years and years and years
starting all the way back with einstein
news board all historians of science say
einstein was wrong boy was right and i
believe it's not true
that's right well nasty nasty questions
on the t-shirt
nasty questions does fit on a teacher
that's good leonard yours
well just with respect to what um gerard
says
um i wouldn't bet against what he says
on the other hand i just can't see how
it will work
but uh it's those kind of conflicts
which get us where we want to go
but my t-shirt well if you can't say the
brooklyn dodger dodgers i guess i would
like it to say
the uv-ir connection now the reason i
think that i
say that is to give me an opportunity to
explain something else
give me five more minutes to explain
something else which we will probably
all agree about
but which is a very bizarre property of
what the of nature
at least if the ideas we're talking
about are correct uh it's it's not
totally surprising that as you try to
get a more and more and more
accurate description of nature it looks
more and more scrambled
uh to get the best description of nature
you have to account for
all the degrees of freedom and sometimes
it's just too much of a good thing i
mean you know we know what happens when
you try to have
too much information too much
information
can lead to a situation where you're
just completely confused because you
just flooded with it it would be like
you you t you mount a camera over the
city of new york you put a
light on everybody's head and over time
you specify where they go
it looks great for about 10 minutes and
then well even
even even taking a sharp snapshot
at an instant too much information will
flood you
you know we know the cia gets so much
information that it doesn't know what to
do with and uh it's just got too much
it's not too surprising you know you'd
learn much much
less about a body of water with a
surface and so forth if you if i gave
you a description
with a table which just gave you the
position
and the velocity of every single
molecule that would be an impossible
thing to deal with so it's not totally
couldn't windsurf on that information
it's not totally surprising
that the better you try to do in a
better description
the more scrambled it's going to look
what's also
new here is something very different
than in the other situations
in the other situations getting more and
more information usually means
more and more detail about smaller and
smaller distances
what i think we now know is that at some
point that's going to reverse itself
and what's going to happen is when you
look in more and more
detail things will start to look fuzzed
out over
bigger and bigger distances and so in
the end
the most perfect the most accurate
description
and the most scrambled description of
something is going to be stretched out
over the whole
uh boundary of space that's called the
uv-ir
connection and what it means uv stands
for ultraviolet and it really just means
small distances
ir stands for infrared and it means very
big distances
and we're getting a little bit i don't
say confused i'm not sure it's confused
but something is happening where as you
start to look at a system and
more and more and more precision what
you might have thought that you're going
to see
more and more tiny short distance small
distance
precision it's going to start getting
fuzzed out and fuzzed out and fuzzed out
until it's stretched across the whole uh
and that's not simply a feature of the
camera you're using or the resolution
that is a fundamental feature
fundamental
aspect of physics that the better you
try to look
and the more detail you try to see with
the more it's going to be stretched out
and fuzzed out over bigger and bigger
distances
yeah i want to follow up on that so at
least one of the reasons why we're now
more and more convinced that the
holographic principle is really
something that works is constantly from
string theory which is my field
and what happens there is precisely if
you go through this
this step of looking more and more
detailed at what happens in short and
shorter distances
you might be interested in say what
happens inside of our
nucleus inside of our atoms and there's
a nucleus and their quarks and they're
smaller and smaller particles and
suppose again that for a moment you
you would want to forget about gravity
but you start looking
more carefully at what we're made of and
then
then because of this this idea that that
when you start looking at smaller and
smaller
scales or at least it's smaller smaller
distances
suddenly you discover that there's
actually something new happening
and that's something new at least in
terms of your equations
you recognize it as gravity so the
amazing thing is that while you're
actually interested in just looking at
the smallest constituents of matter
without putting gravity in gravity
comes out as something that's sort of
inevitable
and and to me there's an enormously deep
lesson there
uh that that gravity is something that
that you cannot do without
clearly we cannot do without we would
not be sitting here would be floating
in this but although gravity for me and
stephen hawking is kind of a pain in the
ass sometimes but uh
which is why we love to forget about it
but but but gravity is
is inevitable but it's also a door to
this something else
it's a door to this something else but
but
you can get it out of something where
you don't put it in
uh so it's not it's not the starting
point it's it's the output
all right well we're gonna we're gonna
have to wrap this up um let's just pull
the audience uh how many of you clap if
you think that we are just a projection
clap clap if you think that we are
actually real
and and clap if you don't care
you know i would have thought that would
have gotten the biggest clap of all uh
this far downtown um first of all i want
to thank
i want to thank our panel um you've
certainly taken us on a
great journey tonight there's obviously
so much to think about i would encourage
if you're
uh interested in these ideas tomorrow
we're actually doing a rebooting the
universe another exploration of the
universe as an
information space at a panel here i also
encourage you
uh on sunday in the uh kimmel space
upstairs
uh mary simon and the keystone dancers
are gonna be doing a fabulous sort of
uh mapping of uh of dance onto the
messier calendar messier catalog
and objects in the universe so this idea
of one information space mapping onto
another is a theme here at the world
science festival
i encourage you to explore all of it
thank you so much for coming
coming and thanks to the panel